welcome back to CBS this morning we
begin with the senator Bernie Sanders
has won the first in the nation primary
tony is that the CBS News decision does
there he is with Anthony Sal Vaughn toe
they're going to dive into the story
behind the numbers in just a minute but
the headline as you know is this that
CBS News projects the Vermont senators a
winner finishing just ahead of Pete
moody judge Sanders addressed his
supporters last night with victories
behind us popular vote in Iowa in the
victory here tonight we're going to
Nevada we're going to South Carolina
we're going to win those states as well
but the race was closed last night just
like those Iowa caucuses with 97% of the
vote counted Sanders has about 26% to
Pete Buddha judges 24.4% Amy Klobuchar
came in third with nearly 20% an
unexpectedly strong result she finished
far ahead of Elizabeth Warren and Joe
Biden CBS News estimates Sanders and
Buddha judge will each get nine of the
24 delegates at stake while Clos Bashar
gets the other six Buddha judge still
leaves in total delegates winning 23
from Iowa and New Hampshire Sanders is
second with 21 at this very early stage
of the race so let's head over to the
CBS News decision desk Tony is with our
elections in surveys director Anthony
selves on Toth to break down the results
that's a lot of it's Anthony's and
Tony's on Tony's look if you take the
long view regarding last night there's
some really shocking results so if you
zoom in here Bernie Sanders Pete boo to
judge Amy Klobuchar 25 24 and 19 1 2 3
how did they get to that demographically
pulling back here Tony I'm gonna pull
back and show you the story on the map
ok these blue towns are the ones that
boo to judge one and the purple ones are
the ones that Bernie Sanders won I'm
gonna zoom in here and just tell you a
quick story about the cities we're gonna
look at Manchester we're gonna look at
Nashua those are places where Bernie
Sanders ran up the score got a lot of
his State wide margin and part of that
is because he did so well with young
voters who lived there two big cities
where Sanders did well
what was his demographic path to victory
okay let me show you from the CBS News
exit poll and you look at the groups
that Bernie Sanders won first of all
very liberal voters maybe no surprise
there that's been core for him all along
but then those young voters under 45 he
wins them with greater than his
statewide margin you compare that to the
groups that Pete Budaj edge won very
different he won wealthier people
incomes over a hundred thousand and this
Tony is really important he won the late
deciders people who resided in the last
couple of days so does that mean that
the debate on Friday night had an impact
indeed look at this here's from the exit
poll as well when did you make your
decision 50 percent that is
extraordinary that is twice as high as
it was last time and check this out
those who said the debate was important
Amy Klobuchar that's behind her bounce
and then Pete Buddha Jets got the lion's
share of them Joe Biden his campaign are
saying Lou got a look ahead to South
Carolina a more diverse electorate what
are you gonna be looking for as the
campaign continues on to Nevada and the
south there is a split in the Democratic
Party we saw it last night we will
continue to see it and it is people who
say they want to return to the Obama era
and people who say they want more
progressive policies than ever and it's
Sanders who is capturing the more
progressive people but that split
persists that's people want more liberal
policies supporting which candidate
people who want more liberal policies
are looking more at Bernie Sanders but
people who want to return to Obama era
policies those folks is human here have
gone to Buddha judge and gone a
Klobuchar they have picked up some of
what was Joe Biden's support so Joe
Biden's problem is right here these are
people who want to return to Obama's
policies but he's only got 14% of them
Clos Bashar a Buddha judge doing much
better
indeed Anthony thank you very much and
as I toss it back to you guys that is
the other headline coming out of last
night Joe Biden fifth place zero
delegates all right Tony and Anthony
thank you so much we're going to get
some more analysis from Democratic
strategists in just a few minutes